wer so fahre den meister
[Musik]
es ist ja ein bisschen schwierig in
einem zweiten film so die magie des
ersten wieder aufleben zu lassen es ist
ihnen doch ziemlich gut gelungen aber
der film ist viel melancholischer für
sentimentale als der erste insofern
vielleicht gar nicht der klassische
sommerhitze
[Musik]
es sind fast alle schauspieler wieder
mit an bord außer melzer die hier
ausgerechnet die hauptrolle hatte und
donner ist tot also der film spielt zehn
jahre nach dem ersten film und donner
ist seit einem jahr tot und ihre tochter
sophie gespielt von amanda seyfried
versucht eben das hotel das renoviert
hat jetzt wieder neu zu eröffnen und was
neues aufzubauen dort mein gott sie noch
was sie aus diesem haus gemacht hat sie
wollte ihrem stolz machen das macht sie
doch schon ihr ganzes leben
das ist auch so ein bisschen das problem
des films donner war die tragende figur
des films und meryl streep war großartig
im ersten teil und sie hinterlässt schon
eine ziemlich große lücke
im film denkt eben an mehreren wänden
dieses hotel ein bild von meryl streep
und ab und zu gehen die figuren dran
vorbei und schauen hin und sind traurig
und das wird den zuschauern genauso
gehen also natürlich ist dieser film
sehr witzig nur hat man da nicht viel
davon wenn man mit den tränen kämpft
jetzt natürlich nicht von mir ich bin ja
redakteurin bei einer seriösen zeitung
und nicht so leicht ins bockshorn jagen
ich könnte mir nur vorstellen dass es
leute gibt denen das zugeht der indizes
in den gut getan so wie bei einem baum
und war dabei der finden ist
gleichzeitig ein prequel und ein sequel
das heißt die geschichte der tochter von
donna wird weiter erzählt aber es wird
eben auch die geschichte von donner als
junger frau erzählt wie sie auf die
insel kam dies passiert ist das ja nicht
tochter bekam man nicht so richtig
wusste von dieser drei männer die sie
erkannte das kind ist und die jungen
leute machen das auch ganz gut
lady jane spielte junge dollar das
problem bei hier ist nur ein bisschen
dass sie nicht wirkt wie so ein hippie
mädchen von 1979 was ihr eigentlich sein
soll im film sondern sie wirkt
eigentlich wie so ein sexy millennial
der immer gerne jeans trägt und
vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu fröhlich
der sie hatte fast nicht mehr
zurückhalten
das ist nicht verrückt aber fans können
sich freuen weil jetzt auch die lieder
aus der zweiten reihe mal gespielt
werden also die meisten lieder die man
so kennt waren eben schon verwendet
worden für den ersten film dann gab es
noch zwei die im musical vorkamen und
die jetzt im zweiten film dann genutzt
werden
aber es gibt eben auch ein paar die
nicht so bekannt sind zum beispiel kiste
teacher das ist das erste lied im film
andante andante wunderschöne ballade die
kennt jetzt auch nicht jeder aus dem
radio zumindest nicht jeder der erst
anfang der 80er geboren wurde und da hat
es wirklich noch mal was zu bieten
[Musik]
die welt
si
[Musik]